let me start with an important decision
we have taken today since the Eurogroup
yesterday evening agreed to endorse as a
nominee for a new vice-president of the
European Central Bank Luis de índice
today the echoing conceived formally
adopted the recommendation on the
nomination it will be forwarded to the
European consumer which will take the
final decision after consultation with
the European Parliament and European
Central Bank today we had first
opportunity to discuss the final report
of the high-level expert group on
sustainable finance that was established
in December 2016 the report includes a
set of recommendations on the
development of the plan European policy
and provides a framework for further
action as a result the European
Commission announced that it would put
forward on the basis of these
recommendations an action plan on
sustainable finance in March this year
we also adopted two documents to fit
into annual budgetary cycle the
forward-looking one is the consumer
conclusion on the budget guidelines for
2019 in particular we went I want to see
a budget that helps create new jobs
supports the vision and agriculture
foster competitiveness while addressing
challenges like migration security and
protection of borders the European Union
is committed to reach the goals set out
in the Paris agreement however to limit
global warming to well below 2% to 2
degrees Celsius
Europe needs an estimated additional 180
billion euros yearly investment over the
next decades public money will not be
enough we need to mobilize substantial
private capital